Is there a way to practice the hard conversations? 100% there is,
and so many people think they're above rehearsals,
roleplay. Those are,
those are things that are critical to seal performance in the battlefield.
I think a lot of people don't realize that. We actually, we,
we do work rehearsals and walk throughs before every single operation and we try
to mimic that. Maybe it's, you know, we're out training in the desert.
We might even have like, you know,
we might lay out rocks or our put tape on the ground. So it, it mimics bill.
If we, if we, if there's not actual buildings to use for training facilities,
there are, uh, uh,
and we have everyone stand together and their sticks and we know who's getting
on the helicopter here and these guys are gonna be on the second helicopter
there.
Those are the kinds of things that allow people in the dark of night when it's
crazy and it's chaotic to go to the right place, do what they're supposed to do.
Everything is simple as unloading from a vehicle. Just,
we would practice that. We, we, we, we had this, uh,
we had this giant truck that we use when,
when the ID threat started getting really bad in Iraq. Uh, initially, um,
seal seal softeners were riding in the back on benches in the back of a Humvee,
kind of an open bed, like a truck truck tie back. Uh, and then the ID thread,
the road tie bombs are sort of getting so dangerous that we had to put guys
inside armor. And so, uh, that means that the Humvees were,
can only carry five guys, you know, if you don't have guys in the back. So, um,
so we had to take this giant, we call it the man truck and we would,
I think we nicknamed it big Ziff was our, it was our truck and it was a,
it was a big, um, five ton truck and you know,
a flatbed truck and they'd,
I don't know if previous seals or if the army had done it marine,
but we had welded these a a quarter inch steel, uh, plates around it.
And then we had a, than we had a sandbox in the bottom of it.
So that was like our,
that was our protection and most of the sandbags were like torn up cause the
boots going in and out. And so it was, you're just sitting on sand.
So if you got blown up,
it would not have provided a whole lot of protection from me.
But getting blown up in Sandy, getting out of the truck is, is substantial.
When you got 20 guys sit in the back of that truck and there, you know, uh,
with some of our guys, Iraqi, uh, of soldiers that were with us, our junkies,
um, and you got to open swing open this giant heavy, you know,
quarter inch steel doors in the back and then you've got to put a ladder out and
everyone's got to climb down that ladder. That takes some time.
And guess what? That can turn into three stooges real quick.
No doubt. People just fall onto them. We can get injured.
We've had guys fall off in trucks like that and dislocate their shoulders and
literally have to get sent home. But more important if it's,
if it takes three minutes or four minutes to do something like that,
that's three or four minutes that you don't have guns pointed in every
direction. Uh, and it's critical.
So we had to practice that and practice that and practice that until we could do
it in less than 30 seconds. And then if we have two different assault forces,
we got to make sure assault ones line up on the left side of the road,
assault twos line up on the right side of the road.
I mean those things that you, we have to practice over and over and over again.
And it seems really juvenile, it seems very elementary. But if, if you did,
if you took the time to practice that performance,
your performance is so much better when you actually get out in the dark of
night. The chaos of me in an unknown area and worried about, you know,
bad guys and where they are and all those things happening and making sure
people went to the place they need to go. So having those conversations,
practicing it,
sitting down with someone who understands how that person might respond for a
tough conversation, roleplay maybe, you know, they, they, uh, they,
they tried different scenarios where they're, they're really,
it's a softball or easy scenario. It's a difficult scenario. And, and uh,
it's the worst case scenario, worst case scenario. So the more you do that,
the better it is. And this is something that Jocko and I have done quite a bit,
is with comedies we work with is roleplay.
You've got to counsel a guy and it's easy just to say, well, you screwed up.
We're firing you. But if it's, this is a good guy, he messed up.
You got to try to get him on board to use this plan,
or you have to talk him down from doing this out on it. You know,
he did something out in town that is making the company a little about what or
whatever it is, uh, and you have to talk to them.
And that role play is critical and it makes you better and enables you to
perform better. Uh, and so yes, you have to do that. Or hers. Yup.
Three or four iterations with someone dealing with, in a roleplay scenario,
they get better. You can literally see them get better. It's pretty, uh,
pretty cool. We got pretty good getting in and out of big Zev.